cette étoile c'est celle que francine
christophe portait quand elle avait 8
ans pour aller à l'école
en 1944 elle est déportée avec sa mère
dans le camp de concentration de
bergen-belsen en allemagne libéré en
1945 par les troupes russes
elle raconte aujourd'hui son histoire et
sensibilise les plus jeunes on doit le
faire parce que parce qu'il faut pas
oublier et parce que comme je leur
explique ça peut revenir de ré faut les
mettre en garde
pour ça que même temps jamais j'apporte
des photos dans les écoles que comment
croire si je m y avait des morts partout
même ça veut dire quoi d'événements
partout et non pas si je vais revendre
les photos il ya des morts partout on
prendre des images parfois difficiles à
regarder mais indispensable les élèves
de 3e du collège champollion ont pu
poser toutes leurs questions sans tabou
moi c'était surtout les conditions du
camp l'histoire qui se passait là bas
comment est-ce que ça va se passer
puis le détail quand on entend le nom de
victimes
qu'elle évoque ce qu'elle a vécu mais
nous on voit ça en fait dans nos manuels
en images quand on réalise pas alors
quand c'est elle qui parle de vivre on
réalise non c'est impressionnant avait
l'idée avec les collègues d'histoire géo
et de france est de faire un travail sur
le devoir de mémoire sur la transmission
des souvenirs ça permet de voir que
c'est pas juste des photos figé c'est
pas juste ce qu'un professeur raconte
parce qu'il est payé pour ça mais bel et
bien quelque chose qui a existé un
échange riche avec un message
mon message c'est de leur dire que en
dépit de tout la vie est belle